اهلا بكم مشاهدينا في اخبار الساعه من
العربيه نستعرض ونرصد معكم ابرز المستجدات
في العناوين
روسيا تعلن السيطره على اكثر من نصف مساحه
تتقدم في
روسيا تتهم الولايات المتحده بمحاوله
عزلها افريقا وتتعهد بدعم دول قاره
السمراء عسكريا
الكشف عن شبكه غسيل اموال ايرانيه في
بغداد متهمه بنهو ملايين الدولارات عبر
معاملات وهميه
محادثات اسرائيليه فلسطينيه في العقبه
بمشاركه امريكيه مصري اردنيه لتجنب تصاعد
العنف
اهلا بكم مشاهدينا البدايه من تطورات
الحرب الاوكرانيه حيث اعلن قائد قوات فاغن
الروسيه السيطره على بلده التي يقضيني
شمال بخمد في مقاله السلطات الموالي
لروسيا انها تسيطر على اكثر من نصف
المساحه الاداريه الاقليم وشرح كمدونيسكا
الموالي لروسيا في تصريحات صحفيه اشار الى
ان القوات الروسيه تسيطر على اراضي جديده
تتوسع في دنيا يوميا واضاف انه من غير
المناسب الحديث عن مواعيد محدده لانتهاء
العمليه العسكريه الخاصه مضيفا ان كميه
الاسلحه التي تزودها الدول الغربيه تؤثر
على ذلك
فيما نفت هيئه الاركان العامه للقوات
المسلحه الاوكرانيه مزاعم مجموعه فانا
الروسيه بالاستيلاء على قريه يغدي شرق
اوكرانيا وقالت هيئه الاركان للقوات
المسلحه الاوكرانيه قالت ان روسيا تواصل
اليوم تركيز هجومها على طول خط الجبهه
باكمله
مشاهدينا من دينيبرو ينضم الينا موفود
العربيه احمد باكاتو اهلا بك احمد ويبدو
ان المعارك محتدمه في باخموت وقد وصلت الى
مرحله حاسمه كيف تدور هناك احمد
نعم اهلا احمد يعني بالفعل هناك معارك
محتدمه بين قوات فاجنر وبين القوات
الاوكرانيه المتواجده فيما بقي لها في
مدينه بخموت هناك تقدمات لا تنكرها
القياده العسكريه الاوكرانيه في هذه
المدينه لكن التقدمات تقول عنها القياده
العسكريه الاوكرانيه نهايه تقدمات ليست
كبيره هي تقدمات بسيطه القوات الاوكرانيه
تضطر للتراجع هربا من المدفعيه
الروسيه بالفعل هناك تقدم لكنه التقدم
طفيف ليس بالحجم الذي يذكر لكن هناك هجمات
بصوره مستمره على طول الجبهه الشرقيه
بدايتها من كوبيسك شرق خركيز وكذلك ايضا
فيمان
وافديفكا كل هذه الاماكن تتعرض لهجمات
بالمدفعيه وايضا بالطيران من قبل القوات
الروسيه هناك محاولات مستمره للتقدم من
قبل هذه القوات على طول الجبهه الشرقيه
ايضا
القياده العسكريه هنا تقول انها صدقت اكثر
من سبعين هجوما حتى صباح هذا اليوم منذ
الامس وحتى صباح هذا اليوم من القوات
الروسيه وهذا يعني يوضح قوه المعارك
ومحاولات التقدم المستمره من جانب القوات
الروسيه ايضا كان هناك فكره اطلاق لصاروخ
سقط على احد المستوصفات الطبيه مع اسرع
عصابه عدد من المواطنين كما تقول الاداره
المحليه هناك هناك محاولات لبناء
تحصينات
ودفاعات في شبه جزيره القرم كما تقول
المصادر العسكريه هنا تحديدا للهجوم مضاد
وهذا ما يتضح من مما يراه الاوكرانيون من
تدفق للجنود الروسي في هذه المنطقه تم رصد
عدد من السفن الحربيه الموجوده في البحر
الاسود التي ضاعف عددها وسط حتى الان 9
سفن حربيه هي موجوده بالفعل في مهمات
قتاليه لذلك هذه الجبهه الجبهه الشرقيه
تحديدا لجهه تقدم مستمر من قبل
القوات الروسيه لكن بصفه عامه يمكن قول ان
اوكرانيا يقومون بهجمات مضاده عن طريق
الطيران المسير الذي يستهدف تجمعات لقوات
الروسيه في هذه الجبهه في كثير من المناطق
وايضا تقوم بقصف بالنيران المدفعيه لاماكن
هذه القوات لكن بالتاكيد نتفق احمد ان
التركيز بين القوات الامريكيه عفوا قوات
الروسيه وقوات الاوكرانيه حول باخم
التحديدا ما الذي يعني خساره هذه المدينه
بنسبه الاوكرانيين
بخمت احمد اكتسبت اهميتها من طول المعارك
التي جرت فيها هي مدينه او منجم للملح
والحجر الجيري لم تكن بهذه الاهميه ولم
يسمع عنها الكثيرون قبل هذه المعارك التي
اشتدت وتيراتها كون الروسي لم ينجحوا في
السيطره عليها بسرعه كبيره كما ارادوا هو
ما اكسب هذا الزخم الكبير نحو اتحدث عن
مدينه كان يسكنها سبعين الفا بقي الان
فيها 2000 لا يوجد فيها شيء يتحرك سوى
الجنود من الطرفين الجميل المدينه دمرت
بصوره كبيره للغايه
وجدنا او اتحدث لنا المواطنون الذين كانوا
هناك عن ان هناك العديد من
الاناشيد والكثير من العبارات التي تقول
ان بخموت تحب تحب اوكرانيا حتى ان هناك
بعض الفرق الغنائيه الان يعني تغني لهذه
المدينه التي اصبحت اشهر المدن قاطبه هنا
في اوكرانيا لذلك هي يشابه حتى ان الرئيس
الاوكراني ذاته يتحدث عنها بانها قلعه
باتت هامه للغايه نظرا لانها منعت بصوره
كبيره القوات الروسيه من التقدم وكذلك
لانها هامه لانها اذا سيطر عليها الروس
سيكون هناك الطريق مفتوحا الى وكذلك
هاتان المدينتان الهامتان لذلك وجود
القوات الاوكرانيه ووقوفها وصدها لهذه
الهجمات المتتاليه والمستمره من قبل
القوات الروسيه يمنع القوات الروسيه
القوات الروسيه من التقدم السيطره على
بلدات اخرى وبالتالي السيطره على كامل
الاقليم دنياه وهذا يفسر سبب استماته
القوات الاوكرانيه في الدفاع عن هذه
المدينه شكرا لك من دينيبرو كنت معنا موفد
العربيه احمد
فرض الاتحاد الاوروبي عقوبات جديده على
مجموعه فاجنر الروسيه لانتهاكها حقوق
الانسان في كل من افريقيا الوسطى والسودان
ومالي وجاء في بيان للمجلس الاوروبي ان
العقوبات الاخيره فرضت نظرا الى البعد
الدولي للمجموعه وخطوره نشاطاتها بالاضافه
الى تاثيرها المزعزع الاستقرار في البلدان
التي تنشط فيها واضاف الاتحاد 11 فردا
وسبعه كيانات على صله بالمجموعه شبه
العسكريه الى قائمه تجميد الاصول وحظر
السفر في المقابل المشاهدين قال العقيد في
الجيش الاوكراني يورو ماديار لشبكه سي ان
ان قال ان القوات الاوكرانيه تقف في
مواقعها حول بخموت على الرغم من تركيز
القوات الروسيه هجمتها في المنطقه واكد ان
القوات الاوكرانيه يحتفظ بمواقعها في جميع
الضواحي الثلاث لباخمد واضاف ان الهجمات
الروسيه باءت بالفشل ولم تحقق نجاحات تذكر
ايام معدوده امام يفكين هكذا وصف خبراء
ونشطاء معارضون من روسيا وضع رئيس مجموعه
فاجنر الروسيه مؤكدين انه تحول من صياد
قاتل الى وحش حيث اكد هؤلاء الخبراء ان
بريكوجين معرضون للاغتيال او الاقصاء في
اي لحظه وفقا لصحيحه
عدد من مقاتليه قال انهم قتلوا بعد
حضمانهم من الذخيره وهو ما يؤشر على
استمرار الخلاف بين بيجوجين وكبار ضباط
الجيش الروسي بخصوص دعم عناصر فريقه
وتداوي علاقه بينهما بحسب الصحيفه
هذا وشدد الرئيس الروسي فلاديمير بوتين
على ان بلاده لا تملك اي خيار سوى الاخذ
في الاعتبار القدرات النوويه لحلف الناتو
واشار في تصريحات لقناه روسيا الاولى اشار
الى ان الغرب يريد تصفيه روسيا وتقسيمها
الى دويلات يسهل السيطره عليها وقال ايضا
ان الغرب شريك غير مباشر في جرائم
ارتكبتها اوكرانيا بسبب اصراره على ارسال
الاسلحه واعرب بوتين عن استعداده بل
استعداد روسيا للمشاركه في حوار حول
التكافؤ النووي لحلف الناتو وشدد على
ضروره وضع القدرات النوويه لفرنسا
وبريطانيا تحت الرقابه في اي اتفاق
مستقبلي
بدوره اتهم نائب وزير الخارجيه ميخائيل
الولايات المتحده بممارسه ضغوط غير مسبوقه
على الدول الافريقيه في محاوله منها
لعرقله القمه الروسيه الافريقيه المزمن
عقدها بعد خمسه اشهر على حد حوله
واكدانوف في تصريحات نقلتها وكاله التاسعه
الروسيه للانب اء اكد ان الولايات المتحده
وحلفائها يشنون حمله غير مسبوقه لعزل
روسيا سياسيا واقتصاديا بما في ذلك تعطي
القمه الروسيه الافريقيه الثانيه
زاد الغرب الضغط على دول افريقيا من خلال
التهديد بفرض عقوبات ووقف المساعدات
هذا واكد المبعوث الخاص للرئيس الروسي الى
الشرق الاوسط ودول افريقيا ميخائيل
بوردانوف ان روسيا مستعده للتعاون مع
الدول الافريقيه لتعزيز القدرات القتاليه
لقواتها المسلحه وقالب ان موسكو بل قال ان
موسكو مستعده للتعاون مع جميع الاشقاء
الافارقه المهتمين بالتعزيز قواتهم
المسلحه الوطنيه ورفع مستوى قدراتها
القتاليه من اجل مكافحه التهديد الارهابي
واضاف نائب وزير الخارجيه الروسي ان العمل
في المجال العسكري التقني مع الدول
الافريقيه يجري بالتاكيد بشكل منتظم
مشاهدينا ينضم الينا مراسل العربي عضو
الجواد الرشد اهلا بك عبد الجواد وما مدى
القلق الذي يعبر عنه المسؤولون الروس من
سعي الغرب بحسب وصفهم لتحجيم النفوذ
الروسي في افريقيا
مرحبا نعم صحيح ما تقول هذا ما تحدث عنه
ميخائيل بغدانا نائب رئيس النائب ووزير
الخارجيه الروسي حول قلق موسكو من
الضغوطات الغربيه على العديد من عواصم
العالم نحو اتخاذ موقف معاد لموسكو بما
يخص قضيه الازمه الاوكرانيه طبعا موسكو لا
يعجبها كما تتحدث وكما تصرح خلال الفتره
الاخيره الضغوطات الغربيه على الكثير من
ممثلي هذه الدول ان كانوا في مجلس الامن
او في مناصب حكوميه اخرى لذلك طبعا تستنكر
موسكو بشكل كبير كما تحدث بوجدانه يعني
السعي الغربي وسعي واشنطن كما وصفه للضغط
على دول العالم لفرض عقوبات على موسكو
لاتخاذ مواقف سياسيه من هذا الشيء خاصه من
الدول الافريقيه طبعا بما يخص هذا الموضوع
نعم احمد تحدث عن ان الشراكه الروسيه
الافريقيه هي في طور
وخاصه في العمل
والنتاج العسكري طبعا التعاون هو الشيء
كبير كما وصفه بوجدان افتسعه من خلاله
موسكو لدعم الدول الافريقيه والعمل سويا
كما تحدثوا بان الموارد البشريه والموارد
الطبيعيه لدى هذه الدول هي كبيره
والفتره يعني السنوات الاخيره التي مرت
بها القاره الافريقيه وخاصه شمال افريقيا
ويقصد طبعا الدول العربيه كانت صعبه
اقتصاديا وسياسيا وشهدت تقلبات كثيره لذلك
لابد من وضع من ذلك عبد الجواد ان
الخيارات الروسيه لترسيخ نفوذها في
افريقيا هو بالتركيز على الدبلوماسيه وفي
ذات الوقت على الحضور العسكري في افريقيا
نعم احمد يعني هو التفاف كبير من موسكو
يعني بعد ان التفت من جهه الغرب نحو الشرق
في بدايه الازمه نلاحظ الرحلات المكوكيه
لوزير الخارجيه الروسي نحو الكثير من
العواصم الافريقيه طبعا تم خلال هذه
الزيارات طرح افق التعاون العسكري
والسياسي والتبادل التجاري وغيرها من
الموضوعات مع الدول الافريقيه من شرقها
الى غربها وهذا ما يفسر هذه الرحلات
الطويله طبعا
هذه الدول موسكو يعني تسعى لبناء علاقات
جديده مع هذه الدول علاقات تغنيها نوعا ما
كما يتحدث الشاشه الروس عن العلاقات مع
الغرب باعتبار ان الازمه وصلت الى مرحله
طبعا لا يمكن العوده منها بين موسكو
والغرب وهذه الازمه طبعا قد تفرض واقعا
لسنوات طويله يحتاج لتعزيز العلاقات بين
روسيا والعالم الافريقي احمد الرئيس بوتين
له تصريحات اليوم ايضا معه
الاعلام الروسيه حول ضروره التكافؤ النووي
بين روسيا والغرب لو تجمل لنا اهم ما جاء
في تصريحات بوتين اليوم
احمد يعني النقطه الرئيسيه التي بداها بدا
بها بوتين كلامه اليوم هو ان العالم يتجه
نحو التغيير لكنه لا يجب ان يتغير لمصلحه
جهه على جهه اخرى هو تحدث عن ضروره تمكن
جميع الدول من الحصول على حقها في اتخاذ
مواقفها السياسيه في العمل مع الجهات التي
ترغب طبعا تطرق للحديث عن امن روسيا
ووضعها الاستراتيجي وان موسكو تسعى جاهدا
بكل الوسائل مهما كانت عسكريه ومهما كانت
نوع السلاح المستخدم للحفاظ على وضعها
وعلى امنها طبعا طرح قضيه مراقبه الملف
والسلاح الاستراتيجي لدى بريطانيا وفرنسا
وانه لا يمانع طبعا دخول الناتو في
مفاوضات وفي احاديث وفي نقاشات حول السلاح
الاستراتيجي والصواريخ التي علقت موسكو
العمل عليه في الوقت الحالي احمد من موسكو
كنت معنا مراسله العربيه عبد الجواد الرشد
شكرا لك يا عبد الجواد
نشرت وزاره الدفاع البريطانيه صوره عبر
الاقمار الاصطناعيه لمركبات روسيه مدمره
تقول انها تابعه لقوات النخبه بالفوج 155
من موشاه البحريه الروسيه في منطقه
وذكرت وزاره في بيانها اليومي ان هذه
القوات كانت في طليعه المهمات التكتيكيه
في منطقه على عكس المعتاد حيث تقوم القوات
المحموله جوا بهذه المهمات ولفت الى ان
مشاه البحريه الروسيه تكبدت خسائر وصفتها
بالثقيله في فوليتر
هذا وتجمع المئات من المتظاهرين في
العاصمه الامريكيه واشنطن بينهم اوكرانيون
يعيشون في الولايات المتحده للاحتجاج على
ما اسموه غزو اوكرانيا والمطالبه بمزيد من
المساعدات العسكريه من واشنطن النشطاء
مشاهدينا رفعوا لافتات تطالب بوقف ما
وصفوه بالاباده الجماعيه وملصقات تسخر من
الرئيس بوتين وبداوا المسيره بدايه من
البيت الابيض وصولا الى مقر اقامه السفير
الروسي في واشنطن
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
اما في المانيا مشاهدينا فطالب الالاف من
المتظاهرين بارساء السلام في اوكرانيا عبر
التفاوض مع روسيا وعدم تسليم الاسلحه
الاوكرانيه وبالتزامن نظم المتظاهرون في
كندا مظاهره مشابهه طالب فيها بعدم تاجيل
الازمه الاوكرانيه مؤكلين على ضروره اجراء
موحدات سلام بدلا من ارسال الناتو اسلحه
الى اوكرانيا نتابع
[موسيقى]
مستمر مشاهدينا وفيها بعد الفاصل للاسبوع
الثامن على التوالي مظاهرات حاسده في
اسرائيل احتجاجا على مشروع التعديل
القضائي الذي يتبناه نتنياهو
اهلا بكم مشاهدينا من جديد شارك مئات
الالاف من الاشخاص في احتياجات ضخمه جديده
ضد الاصلاح القضائي المثير للجدل الذي
قامت به الحكومه الاسرائيليه حسب ما ذكرت
وسائل اعلام اسرائيليه وذكر صحيفه الجيلز
ان المتظاهرين تجمعوا في جميع انحاء
اسرائيل مساء السبت مشيره الى ان المظاهره
الكبرى شهدت مئات الالاف من المشاركين
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
العربيه ببدء اجتماع العقبه بين كبار
المسؤولين الامنيين والسياسيين
الاسرائيليين والفلسطينيين بمشاركه
امريكيه مصريه المباحثات ستشمل ملفات
سياسيه وامنيه وعسكريه وذلك بهدف وقف موجه
العنف التي اندلعت خلال العشر الاخيره
واضاف المسؤولون لرويتا زنا الاجتماع
سيعقد ليوم واحد في ميناء العقبه على
البحر الاحمر بحضور مبعوث الرئيس الامريكي
في الشرق الاوسط
كما سيجتمع كبار قاده الامن الاسرائيليين
والفلسطينيين للمره الاولى منذ عده سنوات
بالاضافه الى ممثلين عن اطراف سياسيه بل
اطراف الرئيسيه في المنطقه في المقابل
المشاهدين استنكرت فصائر فلسطينيه مشاركه
وفد من السلطه في الاجتماع قالت انه
استكمالا لما وصفته بمخططات التامر على
الشعب
هذا وكشف تقرير صحفي اسرائيلي ان رئيسي
جهاز الامن العام شباك سيشارك في القمه
الامنيه المقرر انطلاقها في العقبه
بالاردن وقال موقع ولا انبار سينضم للوفد
الاسرائيلي المكون من مستشار الامن القومي
صحيحا بي ومدير عام وزاره الخارجيه
ومنسق العملي الحكومي في المناطق
الفلسطينيه اللواء الاسرائيلي غسان عليان
ان مشاركه
التي يليها الشابات لوقف التصعيد الامني
في الضفه الغربيه حتى لا يتحول الى
انتفاضه جديده
من القسم المشاهدين
وباي عين يراقب الفلسطينيون والاسرائيليون
اجتماع العقبه اليوم
في الاراضي الفلسطينيه لا يريدون رؤيه هذا
الاجتماع شعبيا اقصد هناك نوع من الغضب
والرفض لهذا الاجتماع كونه ياتي بعد
يصفونها بمجزره نابلس التي قتلت فيها
اسرائيل احد عشر فلسطينيه واصابت اكثر من
مئه على الجانب الاسرائيلي لا مبالاه
تقريبا شعبيا لان اسرائيل غارقه في امور
اخرى تماما مثل الانقلاب على القضاء
والمظاهرات وهذا جل ما يهتم به الاعلام في
اسرائيل لكن بين هذا وذاك علينا ان نقول
بان هذه القمه لم يخطط لها بعد ما حدث في
نابلس وان قبل ذلك عندما كان بلينكن هنا
في المنطقه اتفق مع الطرفين على ضروره عقد
هذه القمه في العقبه في محاوله للجم
الاستيطان الاسرائيلي في مقابل نوع من
اداء للسلطه الفلسطينيه في شمال الضفه
المعتله حيث لا سيطر في نابلس وجنين لا
للسلطه ولا لاسرائيل في مقابل يعني مقايضه
وقف التوسع الاستيطاني بهذا الامر وجاء
طبعا ذلك ايضا قبل
الاجتماع مجلس الامن الذي دانه الاستيطان
عندها وضعت اللمسات الاخيره على هذه القمه
عمليا طيب زياد بالتوازي مع رفض فصائل
فلسطينيه لعقد هذا الاجتماع هل هناك ايضا
اطراف في الداخل الاسرائيلي ترفض ايضا عقد
هذا الاجتماع وخاصه مع ارتفاع شعبيه اقصى
اليمين بحسب بعض الاستطلاعات في اسرائيل
من بعض الفئات داخل المجتمع الاسرائيلي
هذا صحيح جدا اليمين في اسرائيل محرج
تماما لا يريد اي اتصال علني مع اركان في
السلطه الفلسطينيه خاصه ان هناك يعني
الوزير حسين الشيخ يشارك
في هذا الاجتماع ومستشار الامن القومي
الاسرائيلي لا يريدون هذه الاجتماعات
العلنيه والاتصالات مع السلطه الفلسطينيه
لان لها طابع بالاضافه الى الامني لها
غلاف سياسي وهذا ما لا يريده اليمين في
اسرائيل طبعا هذا يذكر الكثيرين ممن
عايشوا هذا الصراع في السنوات الاخيره في
قمه العقب عام 2003 التي كانت في خضم
الانتفاضه الفلسطينيه الثانيه كانت محاوله
ايضا طبعا على مستوى اعلى اعلى من هذا
المستوى شارك الرئيس الامريكي رئيس وزراء
اسرائيل الملك الاردني ورئيس الوزراء
الفلسطيني محمود عباس لان ياسر عرفات كان
محاصرا في المقاطعه لم تنجح تلك القمه
وحاليا في هذه القمه هناك سؤال كبير حول
النتيجه لانه عمليا حتى لو السلطه
الفلسطينيه حاولت ان تقوم باجراءات امنيه
على الارض هناك امر لا يخضع لمن يجتمعون
في هذه القمه على الارض وهو العمليات
الفرديه يعني فتى في الخامسه عشره يستطيع
ان ينفذ عمليه وان ان يقود ذلك الى نوع من
التصعيد بغض النظر عما سيناقشه المجتمعون
في العقبه وبالتالي الامور مركبه اكثر
بكثير من مجرد اجتماع لاحتواء الامر حاليا
في اسرائيل طبعا الشباك الاسرائيلي قلق
جدا مما يحدث لان التوقعات الاسرائيليه ان
استمرت المواجهه على هذا المنوال بمعنى
اقتحامات اسرائيليه وحصيله كبيره من
الضحايا بين الفلسطينيين وصولا الى شهر
رمضان قد يقود الامر الى حرب شامله
انتفاضه في الضفه وحرب في قطاع غزه السؤال
ليس ما يحدث في العقبه السؤال هو هل
يستطيع نتنياهو ان يمنع وزير الامن
الاسرائيلي الداخلي بن جبير من اقتحام
الاقصى في رمضان هذا هو السؤال ربما الذي
يقول ان كانت تصعيد سيتم ام سيتم باحتواء
شكرا لكم
ومن عمان مشاهدينا ينضم الينا مراسله
العربيه عماد عضايله اهلا بك عماد هل يحمل
هذا الاجتماع طابعا امنيا خالصا ام سياسيا
ايضا بالنظر الى طبيعه الوفود المشارك
المشاركه
ومستوى التمثيل ايضا
نعم احمد هو اجتماع امني سياسي بحسب يعني
حسب الحضور في هذا الاجتماع من مدراء
الاجهزه الامنيه بالاضافه الى وزراء
الخارجيه وايضا يعني المستشارين السياسيين
للزعماء هذا هذه الاجتماعات يعني لها
اهميه كبيره ويولي بها المجتمع الدولي
يولي هناك اهتمام كبير بهذه الاجتماعات
لسببين السبب الاول هو التصعيد في الاراضي
الفلسطينيه والوصول لهذا لتهدئه هذه هذا
التصعيد والتوتر في الاراضي الفلسطينيه
اضافه الى ذلك التوقيت الذي يعني حدث او
حصل به هذا الاجتماع وهو ما قبل رمضان حيث
دائما يعني تحدث التوترات في الاراضي
الفلسطينيه بشكل اكبر واوسع في شهر رمضان
والتزامن مع الاعياد اليهوديه اضافه الى
ذلك ان هذا الاجتماع بعد انقطاع طويل ما
بين المفاوضات الاسرائيليه
الفلسطينيه لذلك هذا الاجتماع يعني له
اهميه كبيره جدا في المجتمع الدولي الاردن
نجحت باستضافه هذا الاجتماع وجمع الاطراف
على طاوله واحده واحده لاعاده يعني
التفاوض واعاده يعني يعني او للوصول الى
تفاهمات وايضا احدث اسرائيل
الالتزام بالقرارات الدوليه والقرارات
الشرعيه وحل الدولتين حل الدوله
وبناء على يعني دوله فلسطينيه
موحده بالاضافه الى يعني تنفيذ القرارات
الدوليه
لمصلحه الطرفين من المعروف ان يعني في شهر
رمضان تبدا اسرائيل باقتحامات للمسجد
الاقصى وايضا يعني
تهديد لبعض المدن ويكون هناك يعني توتر
عالي جدا لذلك هذه الاجتماعات وعند هذه
النقطه عماد يعني
الفلسطينيه
على ضمانات من خلال هذا الاجتماع
وقف تجاوزات اسرائيل ام ان دعنا نقول هل
هناك ايضا طرف يعول عليه وهو قادر ايضا
على تقديم هذه الضمانات
نعم يعول على الطرف الامريكي في هذه
المباحثات ان يكون هناك او يضغط على
اسرائيل وقف التصعيد ووقف التوتر في
الاراضي الفلسطينيه ووقف الاقتحامات وايضا
يعني قتل يعني الشبان الفلسطينيين وهدم
البيوت بالاضافه الى وقف العمليات
الاستيطان لذلك يعني يعني السلطه
الفلسطينيه كانت قد هددت بعدم حضور هذه
الاجتماعات ما لم يكن هناك ضمانات
الضمانات هي يعني وقف اسرائيل لهذه لكل
هذه التصعيد في الاراضي الفلسطينيه من
اقتحامات من هدم للمنازل من بناء
الاستيطانات اليوم يعني يعول على هذا
الاجتماع ان يخرج بتفاهمات اسرائيليه
فلسطينيه للوصول الى حل يعني
وتهدئه الاوضاع داخل الاراضي الفلسطينيه
ما قبل رمضان الاردن يعني موقفه ثابت من
كل هذه القضاء القضايا وخاصه القضيه
الفلسطينيه فيما يخص حل الدولتين وفيما
يخص ايضا الضغط على اسرائيل يعني عدم او
لوقف هذه الممارسات التي من شانها تصعيد
التوتر داخل الاراضي الفلسطينيه والتحذير
ايضا من انتفاضه قادمه في يعني في شهر
رمضان طيب عماد يعني هل ماذا عن جدول زمني
لهذا الاجتماع هل سيكتفى بيوم واحد اما ان
هناك احتماليه لتمديد هذا الاجتماع ليوم
اخر
حسب المصادر الاجتماع بدا قبل ساعه ونصف
من الان الساعه العاشره بتوقيت عمان
وينتهي الساعه الخامسه ايضا سيكون هناك
يعني تصريحات ربما تصريحات صحفيه بالاضافه
سيكون هناك بيان من
سيخرج من هذا الاجتماع يعني توضيح كافه
المجريات ومجريات هذا الاجتماع واللقاء
وماذا توصل الفلسطيني والاسرائيليين حول
كافه القضايا وحول تهدئه الاوضاع في
الاراضي الفلسطينيه قبل كما تحدثنا قبل
رمضان ونشدد هنا في رمضان لان الاوضاع
تتوتر بشكل اكبر في رمضان لان يعني المسجد
الاقصى يامه الاف الالاف من المصلين ويكون
هناك اجراءات استفزازيه من من
الاسرائيليين لذلك يعني هذه الاجتماعات
لها اهميه كبيره جدا يعول عليها لتهدئه
الاوضاع في الاراضي الفلسطينيه ولوقف
اسرائيل شافت الاجراءات منها الاجراءات
الاحاديه الجانب بالاضافه الى الاقتحامات
يعني منع المصلين الفلسطينيين من الصلاه
في المسجد الاقصى معك في متابعه لمجرات
هذا الاجتماع شكرا لك من عمان كنت معنا
مراسل العربيه عماد العضايله تحيه عماد
معلومات حصريه مشاهدينا كشف عنها موقع
اراده
تظهر ان سلسله من الشركات التابعه لقاده
الحرس الثوري الايراني تستحوذ على ملايين
الدولارات باسم المقاومه والعمق
الاستراتيجي عبر معامله وهميه وذلك
بمساعده سفاره طهران في بغداد التي تقوم
بنقل طلب ايران من العراق لتصدير الطاقه
الى الحرس الثوري بدلا من ايداعها في
الخزانه الايرانيه واكدت تقارير ايرانيه
بل تقارير ايران تناسنا على ان شبكه غسيل
الاموال التابعه لفرق القدس تدار تحت
اشراف حامد عبد الله قائد الوحده 400 في
الحرس الثوري الايراني
هذا واكد مدير وكاله المخابرات المركزيه
الامريكيه بالبرنس في مقابله مع شبكه
قادره على تخصيب اليورانيوم بنسبه 90%
خلال اسابيع لكنه قال انه لا يعتقد ان
مرشد الايرانيه اتخذ قرارا باستئناف عسكره
برنامج بلاده النووي واكد في اللقاء ذاته
احتمال ان ترسل الصين مساعدات فتاكه الى
روسيا في حربها ضد اوكرانيا مضيفا ان
الصين تحاول تقييم العواقب في حال زودت
روسيا بالسلاح
اعلن رئيس الهيئه العليا المستقله
للانتخابات في تونس فاروق بوعسكر خلال
مؤتمر الصحفي عقبته الهيئه اعلن ان
البرلمان القادم سيضم
154 نائبا من اصل واحد وستين في انتظار
شغل المقاعد الشاغره واقرب عسكر بتغيير
نتائج في دائرتين وان جميع نتائج اخرى دون
تغيير لن على النتائج النهائيه للدور
الثاني هي الخطوه الاخيره في مسار تنظيم
انتخابات التشريعيه سيقع نشر طبعا قرار
الاعلان بالرعد رسمي جمهوريه التونسيه
وبالموقع الالكتروني للهيئه وتنطلق طبعا
الاجيال الدستوريه المنصوص عليها بالدستور
25 جويليا وهي 15 يوما من تاريخ نشر
القرار طبعا بصفه قانونيه طبعا هذه مساله
عليها لا تتدخل فيها رئاسه الجمهوريه هي
من تتولى دعوه اعضاء المجلس النواب الذين
تم التصريحه بفوز نهائيا دعوتهم بجلسه
الافتتاحيه الاولى في خطوط اسبوعين تقريبا
في غضون اسبوعين من نشر القرار بصفه رسميه
وقانونيه نشاطنا مستمره وفيها بعد الفاصل
توافق امريكي صيني على ضروره الدعم
المجتمع الدولي لاجراء الانتخابات الليبيه
خلال العام الجاري
روسيا تعلن السيطره على اكثر من نصف مساحه
اقليم دونياسكا وفاكنا بتتقدم في بخموت
روسيا تتهم ولايه المتحده بمحاوله عزلها
افريقيا وتتعهد بدعم دول القاره السمراء
عسكريا
الكشف عن شبكه غسيل اموال ايرانيه في
بغداد متهمه بنحب ملايين الدولارات عبر
معاملات وهميه
محادثات اسرائيليه فلسطينيه في العقبه
بمشاركه امريكيه مصريه اردنيه لتجنب تصاعد
العنف
اهلا بكم مشاهدينا من جديد في ليبيا اعلن
رئيس بعثه الامم المتحده للدعم في ليبيا
عبد الله باتيلي ان هوجار الاتفاق مع كل
من الولايات المتحده والصين على ضروره دعم
المجتمع الدولي لاجراء الانتخابات الليبيه
خلال العام الجاري وفي التفاصيل انه اتفق
مع وزير الخارجيه الامريكيه على ضروره دعم
المجتمع الدولي لحل من اجل اجراء
الانتخابات كما اضاف انه اثناء لقائه بناء
ممثل الدائم للصين لدى الامم المتحده تم
التاكيد على ضروره دعم حل وطني للازمه في
ليبيا من خلال انتخابات العام الجاري وفي
السودان مشاهدينا شدد عضو مجلس السياده
السودانيه الفريق ياسر العطا على ان قوه
الثوره هي من يحق لها تسير دفه الانتقال
في البلاد مؤكدا ادراك القوات المسلحه
لاهميه الانتقال لدوله المدنيه ديمقراطيه
دون اقصاء لاحد ودعى العطاء قوه الثوره
المدنيه والمسلحه للتوافق على وثيقه
الفتره الانتقاليه نتابع
لابد من تواضع
هو الثوره
المدنيه والمسلحه للتوافق حول وسيغه
لتسيير الفتره الانتقاليه
وتقويم حكومه غويه
لتنفيذ اهداف الثوره وبناء هذا الوطن
لذا نجد اهميه النعي
باي اجندات حزبيه او شخصيه
فاجنده الوطن والشعب والثوره هي الاولى
هكذا مسؤول في الشرطه المحليه في اقليم
بروشستان في باكستان ارتفاع عدد قتل
انفجار عبوه الناسفه الى خمسه واصابه 16
اخرين وذكر مسؤول الشرطه ان العبوه ناسفه
ثبتت في درجه ناريه بسوق شعبيه وتم
تفجيرها عن بعد وذكر التقارير ان
المستشفيات اعلنت حالها الطوارئ عقب
الانفجار ولم تعلن اي جهه مسؤوليتها عن
الهجوم حتى الان
مشاهديهم الينا مراسل العربيه عبد الرحمن
الميزاني اهلا بك عبد الرحمن بدايه على
ملابسات هذا الانفجار واخر التحديثات حول
اعداد الضحايا
نعم لعل هذا هو ربما الهجوم والانفجار
الاحدث في سلسله الهجمات والتفجيرات التي
تشهدها باكستان منذ بدايه هذا العام وفق
تقارير واحصاءات غير حكوميه فان شهر يناير
الماضي شهد ارتفاع بنسبه ما بنسبه نحو
130% في عدد الهجمات والتفجيرات التي
شهدتها باكستان مقارنه مع الشهر يناير
الماضي نتحدث هنا عن العشرات بل ربما مئات
القتلى والجرحى الذين سقطوا خلال او منذ
بدايه هذا العام منذ اعلان حركه طالبان
باكستان في نهايه شهر نوفمبر الماضي
انهاء الهدنه بينها وبين الحكومه بخصوص
انفجار اليوم الحصيله ارتفعت الى خمسه
قتلى و16 جريحا وفق الشرطه فان الهجوم نجم
عن عبوه ناسفه زرعت على دراجه ناريه حتى
الان لم من اي جهه مسؤوليتها عن هذا
الانفجار لكن هذا الانفجار جاء بعد يوم
من انفجار مماثل او او مشابه استهدف دوريه
للشرطه حيث قتل شرطيا وجرح شرطي اخر عندما
ادى انفجار عبوه لاصقه وضعت في مركبه
للشرطه ادى الى انفجارها
ومقتل شرطيين واصابه اخر
حركه او ما يعرف بجيش تحرير وهي حركه
انفصاليه بلوشيه تبنت المسؤوليه عن هذا
الهجوم يوم امس المنطقه التي استهدفها
الانفجار سوق بركان في مقاطع في اقليم
بلشتان هي منطقه بعيده نسبيا عن الحدود
الباكستانيه الايرانيه او كذلك الحدود
الباكستانيه الافغانيه وهي ربما يمكن ان
نقول انها في وسط البلاد وتنشط فيها عدد
من الجماعات الانفصاليه
لاسيما الجماعات البلوشيه بالاضافه الى
جماعات اخرى ارهابيه يعني حركه تحريم تبنت
هجوم يوم امس لكن لم تعلن اي حركه او اي
جهه مسؤوليه عن هجوم اليوم حتى اللحظه
صحيحه عبد الرحمن
نعم نعم بالنسبه لهجوم اليوم لم تعلن اي
جهه مسؤوليه عن هذا الهجوم ربما لان كما
يبدو ان جل الضحايا هم من المدنيين وعاده
هذه الحركات
تحاول ان ناي بنفسها عن مثل الضحايا لكن
حتى الان لم لا يوجد هناك اي اي بيان من
هذه الجماعات في تبني هذا الانفجار او
نفسه لكن هذا الانفجار
ادى الى موجه من الاستنكار والتنديد من
قبل المسؤولين الباكستانيين رئيس وزراء
طالب بتقرير فوري واكد على معاقبه الجناه
وجلبهم للعداله
وطالب الاجهزه الامنيه
شكرا لك من السماء كنت معنا عبد الرحمن
مشاهدينا اكد الرئيس الامريكي جو بايدن
انه ينوي اعلان ترشحه لولايه ثانيه في
الانتخابات الرئاسيه المقرره في 2024 لكنه
لن يقدم على هذه الخطوه الان نتابع
ينوي الترشح لولايه ثانيه في انتخابات
الرئاسه 2024
الرئيس الامريكي لن يحدد متى سيقدم على
الترشح للرئاسه
ردا على سؤالنا جب بيضا بمسحه من البدايه
كانت الترشح لولايه فاكهه
يؤثر عمر الرئيس الامريكي على الترشحه من
المشروع ان يثير الناس قضايا تتعلق بعمره
الفحوص الطبيه تدعم بايدن صحته جيده وقادر
على اداء واجباته
السيده الامريكيه الاولى
سبقته بحسم ترشحه زوج
ي هو تحديد
ما سيتم الاعلان عن ذلك
مع بعض من الضحك والسخريه اكد رئيس
الامريكي جو بايدن نيته الترشح لولايه
ثانيه وهو امر اتبعه الرؤساء الامريكيون
واحزابهم في التاريخ المعاصر
يبدو ان احدهم سال زوجتي عن ترشحه وعلي ان
اتصل بها واسالها الحقيقه ان نيه دائما ان
اترشح لكن علي ان انهي امورا عديده قبل ان
ابدا الحمله الانتخابيه نفهم من كلام
الرئيس الامريكي ان حوضه الانتخابات
المقبله مؤكد لكن اطلاق الحمله الانتخابيه
رهن باعمال الرئاسه وفي مقدمتها الاقتصاد
وحرب اوكرانيا
انا لا
الرئيس بايدن هو خطير على الحزب الجمهوري
لانه السياسه التي يقوم بها واداره الرئيس
بايدن بالفعل بالنسبه للوضع الداخلي هو
وضع اقتصادي ينهار يوما بعد يوم والتضخم
المالي لم يستطيعوا حتى الان لتوقيف هذا
التضخم المالي الحاصل وثانيا بالنسبه
للسياسه الخارجيه هناك وجه اخر لترشح بيضا
عن الديمقراطيين فشعبيه نائبه الرئيس كمال
هاريس ليست عاليه وربما تخسر الانتخابات
امام الرئيس السابق والمرشح الجمهوري
دونالد ترامب فالناخبون يفضلون الجمهوريين
لكن من المرجح ان ينتصر بيضا على ترامب
بنسبه 3% فيما تخسر هرس امام الرئيس
السابق بنسبه 5%
ما زالت الانتخابات الرئاسيه الامريكيه
تقوم على سؤال اساسي وهو فوز او خساره
ترامب فهكذا كانت في الدولتين السابقتين
وهي هكذا الان ربما الرئيس ترامب ضعفت
شعبيته منذ سنتين ولكن اليوم نشعر بان
شعبيته تزداد يوما بعد يوم لانه بالمصائب
التي تضرب الولايات المتحده السياسه
الداخليه والخارجيه واداره الرئيس بايدن
لم تتعاطى معها
بالواجب حسب قدره الولايات المتحده ربما
نشهد في الانتخابات المقبله اعاده لمشهد
العام 2020 جزء اساسي من ذلك هو المنافس
الشخصيه بين الرئيس الحالي جو بايدن
والرئيس السابق دونالد ترامب في الغنم
العربيه واشنطن
مشاهدينا مع ثمار تعليق اشتراط التركيه
لدراسه في الولايات المنكوبه جراء زلزال
تتفاقم معاناه الاطفال الناجنه من الكارثه
في الخيام والملاج الامر الذي دفع بعض
المتطوعين الشباب في هاتاي الى تخصيص
مساحه لاستقطاب الاطفال الرسمي واللعب
النسياني حول الكارثه ولو مؤقتا مفرد
العربي
من التفاصيل
الاطفال وبقدر ما كانوا الاوفر حظا
بالنجاه من تحت انقاذ الزلزال المدمر
بتركيا اصبحوا اليوم الفئه الاكثر تضررا
من صدمه الكارثه اثار الصدمه علقت في
اذهانهم فصارت مضمونه لرسومات تخطها
اناملهم
في البيت وفي الشارع لكن الان انا لا العب
بسبب وفاه ابنه عمي في الزلزال ويضم صرع
النمبر
قلت نائمه حين حدوث الزلزال فايقظتني امي
كانت زلزال مروعا وعند هروب مع ابي وامي
انهارت بنا سلالم البيت
ونحن هنا نهتم بالاطفال كما تعلمون فان
مساحات اللعب المخصصه لهم قد دمرت واللعب
بالقرب منها خطير هنا يلعبون ويرسمون
ويعبرون عن مشاعرهم فالرسم من افضل الطرق
للتعبير عن المشاعر ومحاوله نسيان ما
شاهدوه من صور الدمار والماسي
لوحات بريئه قد لا تصمد طويلا على سياج
هذه الساحه في هاتاي لكن المشرفين على
المبادره ياملون في ان تساعد الاطفال على
نسيان جراح الزلزال المدمر العالقه في
ذاكرتهم
نحاول ازاله اثار معاشه الاطفال الماساه
اثر الزلزال عبر هذه المساحه التي تحتوي
على العاب وكتب للمطالعه والرسم ونؤمن لهم
الطعام كذلك وكما تعلمون المدارس مغلقه في
الولايات المتضرره والاطفال يحتاجون الى
الرعايه والتعليم
تشير التقديرات الاوليه الى تضرر اكثر من
مليوني طفل من الزلزال في تركيا فيما تحذر
منظمه اليونيسيف الامميه من تبعات ذلك
عليهم مثل هذه الفضاءات المخصصه للاطفال
وفي هذا التوقيت بالذات ستجنب لا محاله
مالات غير محموده لهذه الفئه التي عاشت
هولك كارثه الزلزال المدمر دعم نفسي
ومرافقه بمختلف الانشطه قد تعيد لهم مهجه
الحياه من جديد عبد القادر خربوش العربيه
هاتها جنوب تركيا
بعد انسحاب شركات السينما الغربيه من
روسيا انخفضت نسبه الزائرين لدور السينما
الى ما يقرب من اربعين في المئه لتصبح
معارضه للاغلاق وسط تساؤلات فيما اذا كانت
الافلام الروسيه قادره على انقاذ هذه
الصناعه
بعد مرور اكثر من 30 عاما على انهيار
الاتحاد السوفيتي تعود الان الى شاشات
السينما الروسيه الشخصيات الكرتونيه
السوفييتيه الكلاسيكيه بعد اعاده احياء
العديد من هذه الاعمال من جديد للرفض
بدانا في شهر يناير بعرض فيلم
حضورا كبيرا
ثلاثه عوامل متزامنه ساعدت على زياده
شعبيه هذا الفيلم وهي اولا نقص الافلام
المعروضه وبسبب شعبيه الشخصيه الكرتونيه
السوفييتيه
ولان عرض الفيلم تزامن مع عطله راس السنه
فيلم الرسوم الكرتونيه السوفيتيه تشوبر
احد الافلام التي اعيد احيائها من جديد
الان حتى ما الارقام القياسيه بنسبه
المشاهده في روسيا التي بلغت نحو 10
ملايين مشاهده واحتل المركز الاول في شباك
التذاكر بين الافلام الروسيه بعد تسعه
ايام فقط من اطلاقه
النادي السينمائي الدار الذي يديره الفنان
الشعبي الروسي اوليج متيافا اسس من قبل
مخرجين نلحقبه السوفيتيه ويعرض بشكل دائم
الافلام من تلك الفتره والتي تلقى حضورا
كبيرا حتى الان حاله الحنين لدى المواطنين
الروس ليست فقط الى الاعمال الفنيه في
الحقبه السوفيتيه وانما الى كل ما يتعلق
بهذه الفتره من تفاصيل الحياه اليوميه
خبراء فنيون تحدثوا عن ان نجاح هذه
الافلام الان يعود الى وجود حاله من
الحنين الى الاعمال والشخصيات في الحقبه
الس وفييتيه من قبل الصغار والكبار وحتى
المتقاعدين من الروس وسط غياب للافلام
الهوليوديه بعد حظر عرضها على الشاشات في
روسيا كاتيا طعم العربيه موسكو في سياق
اخر مشاهدينا السلطات في كوريا الشماليه
منعت افلامه في البلاد تماما وتوعدت
اولياء الامور بعواقب قاسيه في حال سمح
لاطفالهم بمشاهدتها
ممنوعه في كوريا الشماليه بامر من كم
اولياء الامور في كوريا الشماليه تلقوا
تحذيرا من عواقب قاسيه
العواقب تشمل ارسال والد الطفل الى معسكر
عمل لسته اشهر
[موسيقى]
طالبت الاهالي بتثقيف ابنائهم وفق المثل
الاشتراكيه واذا لم يقم الاباء بتعليم
اطفالهم فسوف يرقصون ويغنون عن الراسماليه
ويصبحون معادين للاشتراكيه
قرار منع افلام هوليود سبقه قرار تغيير
اسماء الفتيات اللائي يحملن اسم ابنه
روسيا تعلن السيطره على اكثر من نصف مساحه
واشنطن بمحاوله عزبها افريقيه وتتعهد بدعم
دول القاره السمراء عسكريا
الكشف عن شبكه غسيل اموال ايرانيه في
بغداد متهمه بنهب ملايين الدولارات عبر
معامله وهميه
محادثات اسرائيليه فلسطينيه في العقبه
بمشاركه امريكيه مصريه اردنيه لتجنب تصاعد
العنف في امان الله مشاهدينا
[موسيقى]